le réseau social instagram vous allez
souvent sur ce réseau social bah oui les
autres eh bien figurez vous qu'il est au
coeur d'une nouvelle polémique
on l'avait pas vu venir celle ci
vraiment la plateforme serait en effet
accusé de grossophobie par certains
internautes
et c'est charles manière de bourdin
direct nous explique tout cela le mot
gros c'est dangereux selon instagram
c'est le constat qu'ont fait plusieurs
internautes lorsque vous tapez le mot
grosse dans la barre de recherche un
message apparaît attention les
publications que vous recherchez
encourage souvent un comportement
pouvant nuire ou conduire au décès si
vous traversé des moments difficiles
nous sommes là pour vous aider vous avez
alors le choix soit poursuivre votre
recherche accéder aux publications du
hashtag grosse soit instagram vous
propose une liste de conseils pour vous
venir en aide
une sorte de mise en garde le même
protocole que pour les mots suicide ou
automutilation mais évidemment classé le
mot grosse dans la même catégorie que le
suicide est une pratique curieux grosso
fob oui selon plusieurs militantes qui
se sont mobilisés elle accuse instagram
de vouloir cacher les corps des femmes
en surpoids une forme de discrimination
supplémentaire pour ces militantes
alors qu'est ce qu'on en pense et ce que
instagram est grosso fabas que cette
l'enfer est pavé de bonnes intentions
est ce que ce qu'ils ont voulu faire
c'était plutôt bien et puis ça a été mal
pris j'aimerais bien avoir votre
sentiment là-dessus on va commencer par
vous et emilie va franchement j'ai pas
compris la polémique alors je sais que
quand je vous ai dit tout à l'heure en
loge je vous ai voulu m'expliquer non
j'ai compris oui mais je n'ai pas
compris le pourquoi du comment
pour vous il ya un gros lobby là dedans
non moi mon sens ils ont fait ça
pourquoi il l'expliquera bien c'est
serré certains mots qui encouragent
souvent un comportement pouvoir nuire et
donc en gros mois j'ai vu ça comme une
façon d'éviter le harcèlement qu'on peut
avoir sur les réseaux sociaux et pour
une fois qu'on en a un qui se sort un
petit peu les doigts du c ans et qui
essaye de faire quelque chose on y tombe
sur le coin du bec et franchement j'ai
voilà j'ai pas compris puisque mais pour
rejoindre ce que est ce que vous pouvez
envisager que effectivement ça semble
une bonne volonté mais que ça puisse
être mal mal compris parce que après
tout gros c'est pas cessé sélectionner
qu'un adjectif ce n'est pas limitatif je
suis désolé patrick candidate qui nous
regarde et qu'on vous traite de grosse
sait jamais hein
primo maintenant elle suggéré
on repart sur le débat qu est-ce que
c'est bien de dire gros que maigre non
moi je ne pense pas j'ai grosse assise
bassi parce que c'est sous une insulte
de dire tu es grosse ça n'en ai jamais
de dire tu es maigre je suis sonné pour
une personne qui est maigre c'est pas
non plus agréable de 2 prendra de quoi
se mêle un seul gramme
mais de quoi se mêlent instagram moi
c'est la question que jouer comme les
jeunes attention derrière rodez mais non
mais de quoi se mêle un accord à louis
hémon ce réseau social peut estimer que
tel mot ou tel autre devrait être plus
ou moins utilisé c'est à moi je
comprends très bien que les gens soient
choqués je comprends je ne vois pas de
quoi je ne vois pas je ne vois pas
pourquoi gross est devenu tout d'un coup
une insulte suprême lécher le prochain
c'est quoi mais caroline soulève quelque
chose c'est vrai que instagram a choisi
ce mot clé là à ce moment là pourquoi
ils n'ont pas choisi comme mot clé le
mot suicide par exemple ou quand vous
tapez par exemple un au rexy vous avez
exactement le même le même message
voilà les demandes et j'ai encore testé
cet après midi des toits sur des chats
nourrissent ils adorent et qui s'est
passé mais ça n'a rien à voir avec le
mot gauche je t'explique que sur
certains hashtag effectivement ils ont
mis exactement le même message et s'il
manque une femme parce qu'ils entravent
la liberté de parler de ce mot qui est
un adjectif qualificatif qui désigne
quelque chose mais pas tous et pas
seulement une période fond du petit
meuble est une insulte
pourquoi avoir créé la liberté 2 2 par
les jeux de rôles assez non pas parce
que le problème c'est que toi on te je
sais tu vas encore que c'est une bulle a
jamais reçus caro tu sais pas ce que ça
fait de voir quelqu'un qui te ment à
chaque grosse sûreté commandes sur tes
commentaires sur instagram la sueur sur
le fond des choses le problème c'est de
savoir si on laisse le droit
instagram à facebook à tous les réseaux
sociaux a snapshot le droit de gérer la
morale de gérer le civisme et de schiste
gérer les mots qu'ils veulent mais dont
l'essentiel l'exemple non mais non mais
on ne peut pas leur reprocher tout et
son contraire c'est à dire on peut pas
leur dire vous ne faites rien et quand
il faut le leur reprocher ils servent il
sera probablement donne en se dorant une
baisse donnant une belle image en
faisant ce genre de choses je vous donne
un exemple moi en faisant un live il y
avait un tableau dernièrement une
reproduction de la danse de matisse on
voit des corps informe l'oeuvre y envoie
ouais ils m'ont fermer mon compte parce
que nudité par contre quand il ya un
type qui met un truc de terrorisme il
faut deux jours avant de supprimer c'est
drôlement bizarre donc ils servent leurs
intérêts avant tout juste à géométrie
variable
ces revues encore très bien et que les
petits bouts comme jean michel comme
caroline ils ont raison de dire
instagram et de l'impôt de l'apostrophé
tu veux on te en effet instagram
parce que dès le départ si on avait pris
le problème à bras le corps c'est à dire
de la censure du mot clé celui qui
intéresse tout le monde et moi le
premier vous me connaissez valérie le
mode et on a payé et personne n'a rien
dit sur ce plateau
vous tapez et et on vous ne tombiez sur
aucun piéton sur instagram
ce n'est pas l'avis finalement à
pardonner à quel moment vous ça pète et
on vous aussi avait toujours très bien
vous mettre en joie
non mais ce que vous êtes effectivement
ce que vous dites les uns et les autres
c'est que il ya une sorte d'ingérence
c'est ça bah oui et en même temps on
leur demande aussi d'avoir cette
ingérence et pour éviter les messages
haineux les messages non on est vous
voulez passer mais en quoi le mot gros
sa rue ou gros devient du coup quelque
chose d'hyper stigmatisant et de
nécessairement injurieux et où le maigre
les obèses puisque d'autres noms qui
sont à faro bells d'accord donc vous il
faudrait répertoriés toute une liste de
mots ou carrément forestois tout soit
rien d'accord soit vraiment on cible une
certaine forme de violence le racisme
l'antisémitisme et ses enfants la
grossophobie l'homophobie etc sachez
vallée et sachets valérie qu'aujourd'hui
en 2019 souvent on dit salut gros mais
ça ne veut pas dire personne et gros
c'est ok en gros censuré sur instagram
parce que vous êtes pour est ce que vous
êtes contre et vous êtes contre à 60 2 %
pour 38%